this just in visitors from beyond the
stars have arrived
what secrets could our intergalactic
friends share what wonders could these
space Jung's unveil they do not come in
peace
the aliens have arrived and they're here
to lay down the law humans are no longer
at the top of the food chain and we're
now at the mercy of our alien overlords
I for one welcome our alien overlords
what would our new alien masters do with
us and why did they invade Earth this is
what if and here's what would happen if
we became enslaved by aliens for
centuries humans have been calling the
shots on earth just ask the animals we
use as food keep in zoos hunt for sport
or even have around the house as pets
we're in for quite the shock when our
new intergalactic masters show up and
give us a taste of our own medicine what
exactly would they do to us
well we may become the new animals
we'd be treated as a commodity to be
bought traded and sold and if these
aliens are anything like we are we'd
also be their lunch human cells are made
up of proteins nucleic acids and
membranes if the aliens had the same
basic biochemistry as us they would be
able to convert our tasty nourishment
filled bodies into energy for themselves
would aliens start farming us on mass
what sort of intergalactic economy could
be created by using humans like
livestock in China alone the pork
industry is worth 128 billion dollars
and has 433 million pigs ready to
barbecue there are 17 times as many
on the planet to an alien food
connoisseur would we be just as tasty
human burger anyone what if we were seen
as a delicacy to be distributed across
the universe or what about just pieces
of human even to us body parts are a hot
commodity a heart is 1.4 million dollars
to transplant and worth 119 thousand
dollars on the open market kidneys are
around the 200 thousand dollar mark
livers are one hundred and fifty seven
thousand and bone marrow is twenty three
thousand dollars a gram we're dealing
with human economics here but this idea
can be applied to the concept that we
are Earth's new cattle we're a living
organism that might be sold to someone
or something
somewhere in space but what if the
aliens didn't think we were delicious
what if they thought we were cute well
in the u.s. there are nearly 70 million
dogs being kept as pets and 74 million
cats Brazil has 191 million feathered
best friends with the aliens keep us as
pets or even worse what if they kept us
in captivity and gawked at us you know
like we do with animals and zoos
there are approximately 6,000 species in
zoos around the world about 8 million
animals in total the aliens may not have
as much variety in human zoos but we
sure are an entertaining Bunch imagine a
group of alien children on a school trip
watching you in your natural habitat see
children lectures the alien headmistress
the human is on its phone again so
there's not a lot to look forward to but
it makes us think about what the aliens
would get out of Earth in the first
place well the earth looks like a nice
place to set up shop
on paper Earth has plate tectonics that
help to keep the climate stable a global
magnetic field that keeps solar winds
from getting close and the added bonus
of a moon that stops Earth from wobbling
on its axis too much that combination
would look appealing to the aliens and
it's something they might have a
difficult time finding anywhere else and
what about us well we already know we'd
not only be delicious but profitable
with the aliens having a monopoly on the
human market they could start making
more rewarding changes to their new home
considering that they're intelligent
enough to travel light-years to get here
how hard could it be to redevelop a
planet for a special bulletin are you
curious about life beyond the stars well
good news friend curiosity's dream is
here to answer your call tune in to
special programs like World War a aliens
invade Earth where leading scientists
and researchers weigh in on the
scenarios that might unfold if
extraterrestrials find us and decide to
visit earth curiosity stream has
thousands of documentaries and
nonfiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers including
exclusive originals and guess what Chum
it can all be yours they're giving what
if viewers access to the site for free
for 30 days after that it's only $2.99 a
month or just $19.99 a year sign up now
at curiosity stream comm slash what if
and use the promo code what if now back
to your regularly scheduled alien
invasion
the truth is we don't know for sure what
the aliens plans would be this is only
one of several scenarios that could
happen if we faced an alien invasion
what if the aliens are already planning
to head our way surveying the land and
getting to know these strange humans who
call earth home what if the aliens were
already watching us well that's a story
for another what if